[Musica]
[Applauso]
da bambino ho sognato di fare mille cose
il primo abito che sogna di indossare fu
quello del benzinaio e lo scrissi in un
tema in seconda elementare
la maestra mediare gravemente
insufficiente perché una bambina non
poteva sognare di fare il benzinaio
tornai a casa lo raccontai a mio padre
il quale sorrise e mi disse cat e la
maestra ragione la benzina puzza la
benzina fa male tu dovrai fare un
mestiere profumato cerca lo è
soprattutto un mestiere che faccia bene
alle medie con obi la mia insegnante di
lettere la adora i sapeva capirmi come
nessuno aveva fatto finora
decisi allora che da grande avrei fatto
anch'io l'insegnante di lettere e avrei
dimostrato al mondo l'importanza della
cultura ma poi in università mi imbatte
in una cazzuola e in quella sensazione
che solo la terra che ti si conficca
sotto le unghie e nelle mani sadar di e
allora tra di linz l'amore per
l'insegnamento e divenni un'archeologa
mio padre mi guardava passare da una
passione all'altra è a metà tra il
rassegnato e il divertito mi lasciava
fare
mia madre invece inarcava sempre più
sopracciglio sinistro
lei che mi sognava in banca con un
reddito fisso una buona famiglia puoi
preparare la cena la sera mi vedeva in
giro per il mondo con uno zaino in
spalla i muscoli sulle spalle
l'abbronzatura era muratore i caldi
nelle mani sono passati 35 anni da quel
monito e da quel tema è ancora cerco il
mio mestiere e il profumo di quel
mestiere
ho ancora negli occhi
mio padre che la sera raccontava del
profumo del frassino del noce dell'olmo
come fossero le fragranze delle sue
migliori amanti faceva il falegname
ho ancora nelle orecchie le parole di
mia madre che alla sera mi ricordava che
finché non finivo quello che avevo nel
piatto non potevo alzarmi da tavola come
notivà più lo sai che in africa i
bambini muoiono di fame
i 17 sosteneva livello admin goals erano
già tutti nelle parole dei miei genitori
una coppia semplice anche un po
ignorante ma che sapeva fare benissimo
il suo mestiere
educare sì sempre generosa sia attenta
agli altri e all'ambiente ma fatte
rispettare
erano tutti lì da circa vent'anni anzi
da più di vent'anni ormai mi occupo di
progettazione per il terzo settore un
ambito in cui le parole responsabilità
contaminazione cambiamento vengono
sempre più svuotate di significato e
utilizzate all'interno di ritornelli
spessissimo retorici sdolcinati eppure
ancora oggi ogni volta che sento
nominare a me emozionano quando un
giorno mi trovo all'interno di una
riunione di lavoro con un potenziale
nuovo cliente ad ascoltare i dialoghi di
un gruppo di insegnanti e di prestiti di
una scuola paritaria del centro di
milano
il pensiero è tornato per un attimo lì a
quel profumo di inchiostro che sapeva
d'uva di una penna viola con cui
scarabocchiava la smemoranda il cui
spessore era sempre raddoppiato rispetto
a quando la comprava la scuola ne
chiedeva aiuto per ripensarsi
riprogettarsi perché le iscrizioni erano
in calo
occorreva forse un nuovo piano di
comunicazione l'acquisto di spazi
pubblicitari in più o forse
l'introduzione di nuove tecnologie più
al passo con i tempi e soprattutto con
l'offerta
che le altre scuole facevano gli
studenti
chiudo gli occhi e cerco il profumo mi
ritrovo in questi corridoi questa volta
con una responsabilità enorme sola
possibilità di entrare veramente in
quello che per me è sempre stato al
tempio del cambiamento
la scuola ascolto registro conversazioni
riguardo e lavorare e intanto continua
il mio lavoro che mi porta a frequentare
sempre più convegni legati a temi come
la responsabilità sociale le
certificazioni ambientali legate al
mondo delle aziende con cui collaboro
negli ultimi due anni partecipo sempre
più spesso a convegni ea tavoli di
discussione su un documento un documento
particolare che nel 2015 viene
sottoscritto dai 195 paesi delle nazioni
unite l'agenda 20 30
mi sento parlare persone provenienti da
ogni ambito ministri politici
imprenditori il mondo della finanza
addirittura in ultimo ma non ultimo ne
sento parlare persino il papa che
contemporaneamente esce con una
enciclica la laudato sii sugli stessi
temi di colpo mi accorgo che all'interno
di tutti questi tavoli non ho mai visto
e non ho mai ascoltato le parole di un
maestro di un insegnante di un preside
eppure la generazione futura di cui
continuiamo a parlare è quella che oggi
è in quelle aule e che oggi ancora
indosso i grembiulini e rose azzurro e
crede nei supereroi
capisco che la proposta da fare alla
scuola del centro di milano può essere
questa diventare la prima sustainable
development school decidiamo di rivedere
la didattica
guardando partendo dall ispirazione dei
17 gol li trovo bellissimi sono colorati
sembrano fatti per i bambini e invece ne
discutono i potenti della terra i 17 ed
i gist riassumono gli obiettivi che
ciascun governo dovrebbe porsi affinché
noi cittadini possiamo dirci fieri di
vivere nel mondo in cui viviamo
riassumono i sogni dei giusti il quarto
parla della garanzia che dovrebbe essere
concessa a tutti di una educazione di
un'istruzione di qualità partiamo dalla
nostra scuola
rivediamo le discipline riportiamo tutto
quanto su 6 ma trovare che riassumono
gli impegni le attenzioni che i nostri
studenti i nostri figli dovrebbero avere
molto più di quanto siamo riusciti a
fare noi
attenzione all'ambiente attenzione alla
persona e alle creature che lo abitano
l'importanza delle lingue come strumento
di incontro e di dialogo con le
differenze e poi le nuove economie i
nuovi mestieri lo sport come palestra in
cui imparare il valore dell'integrazione
della solidarietà e in ultimo l'arte e
la bellezza perché ogni pensiero deve
partire da lì e poi rivediamo le
funzioni della scuola perché lo sviluppo
sostenibile si fa soprattutto fuori
dalle aule scolastiche
la scuola deve tornare ad esercitare il
ruolo politico sui nostri territori per
che maneggia la generazione futura ha a
che fare con gli agenti critici del
cambiamento che non sono le aziende sono
i bambini
e allora affianchiamo alle funzioni
ordinarie della scuola un team di
professionisti presi dal corpo docente
stesso che aiutano la scuola a curare le
relazioni le relazioni con la società
civile con le istituzioni con le aziende
con le università e poi qualcuno che
curi l'esercizio dell'iss
azione e del fornire contenuti educativi
anche sui nuovi spazi educativi che sono
quelli non formali sono quelli digitali
sul web attraverso i social e qualcuno
che si occupi di quello che in
un'azienda si chiama ufficio ricerca e
sviluppo perché la scuola deve stare al
passo con i tempi
e ancora qualcuno che si occupi del
fundraising per rendere sostenibile
prima di tutto dal punto di vista
economico il piano operativo che
ciascuna scuola e poi ideare la buona
scuola
io credo sia quella che insegna niente
di più e niente di meno che la classica
buona educazione
come la intendevano i miei genitori
quella che è capace di trasferire ai
nostri figli studenti allievi quei
valori per cui l'adozione di quegli
stili di vita sostenibili su cui si
arrovellano oggi i governi di tutto il
mondo diventano scontati diventano
spontanei perché attraverso il
trasferimento di quei valori di quelle
competenze di quelle abilità noi
generiamo delle persone di valore nel
lavoro e nella vita nella scuola e nel
centro di milano non vi ho detto una
cosa importantissima i bambini entrano a
3 anni ed escono a 18 pronti ad
affrontare i migliori atenei di mezzo
mondo
abbiamo una scommessa da vincere
importantissima e allora mi rivedo
bambina sempre con le toppe sui
maglioncini e sulle camicie e quando
tornavo a casa un po intimidita con
questa macchia che cominciava a vedersi
sul gomito andavo da mia madre che
invece mi premiava facendomi scegliere i
colori delle top ed applicare e mi
diceva sempre di essere orgogliosa di
portare le toppe sui gomiti perché
voleva dire aver per passato molto tempo
a fare esercizio ea pensare alle
e in quel pensare lei ci metteva tutto
quel dono e quel privilegio
dell'istruzione e della cultura che
doveva essere sempre alla base di ogni
azione che non era così scontata per lei
non lo era stato allora se io oggi
potessi sceglierei per i nostri bambini
17 colori diversi per le loro top e uno
per ogni gol e augurerei loro sempre
dimostrarle con orgoglio perché
significa aver pensato prima di avere
agito qualunque azione per cambiarlo
questo mondo craxi
[Applauso]